[Musique]
bonsoir georges samueli merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france alors
la décision de la cour pénale
internationale qu'elle portait at elle
selon vous n'aura pas du tout des faits
parce que les états unis n'a rien à voir
avec la cpi mais collabore pas avec
cette cour et a signé des accords avec
qui ces états pour démonter ces états ne
connut coopèrent pas du tout avec la
cour concernant des enquêtes contre les
militaires américains tant que cela
n'aura aucun effet il ne faire que
encourager la tuerie américaine que
toutes sortes responsabilité
internationale pour les crimes de guerre
ne devrait pas avoir lieu
alors avant d'aller dans le détail
effectivement de ce que dit cette
décision pour vous déjà ce que c'est une
décision de la cpi qui arrive trop tard
ouais je ne pense pas que ça sera une
question de trop tard ou trop tôt
cela ne change rien parce que les états
unis n'est pas ne participe pas à la cpi
n'a jamais ratifié la cpi et a toujours
été très hostile envers on va cette cour
et as compris tous d'accord avec
d'autres états pour pour la demande et
je n'ai pas coopérer avec la cpi
alors cela n'aura aucun effet
si vous vous en souvenez il ya un
certain taux les états unis n'a même pas
autorisés la procureur de la cpi à
entrer aux états unis c'est assez
extraordinaire
c'est la procureur général de la cpi qui
n'a même pas eu le droit de rentrer aux
états unis
alors c'est une question de deux dents
de certains à certains types de
propagande à l'encontre les états unis
mais cela n'aura aucune ne fera pas du
tout de différence parce que les états
unis ne prendra avec tda et d'autre
l'otan ne va pas collaboré avec la cpi
non pied un compte cette enquête contre
les états unis
vous dites évidemment on a bien compris
aucun effet les états unis vont le
prendre avec dédain il n'empêche
symboliquement ce n'est pas terrible
pour les états unis on le rappelle
enquête pour crimes de guerre et crimes
contre l'humanité dont on le rappelle
encore des exactions qui ont été
commises par des soldats américains
concrètement que leur reproche-t-on
c'est emblématique oui et ils sont
accusés des crimes de guerre assez
sévère et nous savons que les états unis
ont bien commis des crimes de guerre en
afghanistan en irak et dans bien
d'autres pays
le problème c'est que la cpi n'a pas de
même n'a pas de compétence pour enquêter
sur n'importe quel parti autre que les
spas les pays du tiers monde en afrique
notamment parce que les payes puissant
n'accepte pas de droits de la série
d'enquêtés sur eux ils veulent bien
qu'ils enquêtent sur l'afrique sur dp
de l'asie peut-être mais ils n'ont pas
donné le droit à la cpi pour enquêter
sur un thème de sa valeur emblématique
dans les années 80 la cour
internationale de la justice qui a
acquis et puis qui sait que la cpi a
jugé très sévèrement les états unis dans
le cadre de sa guerre au nicaragua est
des états unis a riposté à cette cour
qui est très puissant qu'eux ils
voulaient n'ont rien avoir à faire avec
la décision alors mecs m'ont bo lui même
disait symbolique quand même ils
réagissent dénonce une enquête y
réfléchit est ce que il a des craintes
quand même michael pompéo ça devrait pas
trop lui plaire quand même d'être
montrés du doigt comme ça non loeb
n'aura fait bien sûr qui n'est pas
content les états unis n'est jamais
content quand il ya une question de sa
responsabilité
sa responsabilité pour ses actions et
bien sûr que il est absolument furieux à
l'été que la cpi aurait aurait la
témérité de accusé les états unis de
commettre des crimes de guerre bien sûr
que les états unis n'a jamais commis de
crimes de guerre ne penserait même pas à
commettre des crimes de guerre
donc il y a une espèce d'hypocrisie de
la part des états unis quant à la cpi
parce que ils étaient très contents que
la cpi enquête sur mouammar kadhafi
qu'elles utilisent les déclarations de
la procureure générale à l'époque contre
kadhafi pour dire voici des évidences de
des crimes commis par kadhafi
alors pour les états unis ça allait très
bien la serbie s'est très bien donc
elles agissent contre les ennemis des
etats unis ou des faits insignifiants
qu'ils n'ont pas de valeur qui n'ont pas
de poids géopolitique
alors revenons à l'accord cette fois-ci
signé entre les états unis les talibans
qui on le rappelle le ouvre la voie à un
retrait total des troupes américaines
d'afghanistan vous voyez ça comment vous
une sorte de stratégie de sortie en
forme de de reddition américaines en
tout cas c'était une promesse électorale
de donald trump avait dit oui au betting
c'est une façon de sortir les états unis
de l'afghanistan c'était de huit
objectifs du président obama il n'avait
pas la force ni le courage de le faire
cela était l'objectif du président john
et tous qui veut faire tout ce qu'ils
veulent obtenir d'eux des talibans
cessez le feu
il s'en fiche ce que la guerre continue
entre les talibans et les forces
afghanes il s'en fiche mais tout ce
qu'ils veulent c'est une promesse que
l'état les veaux ne vont pas collaborer
avec une bêche et al-qaïda en pour
s'attaquer aux états unis c'est tout ce
qu'ils leur intérêt qu'ils veulent bien
que l'état lève on collabore avec tayeb
et al-qaïda s'ils s'attaquent à la chine
ou de la russie
mais tant que ça y est je ne s'attaque
pas aux états unis cela leur a alors
talibans peut très bien dire
nous allons collaborer avec taille et
shehata et de meyer a dirigé contre
d'autres pays les états unis fait sortir
ses troupes d'ici 4 à 14 ans mais je ne
suis pas sûr qu'ils y parviennent alors
c'est vrai que c'est assez audacieux de
négocier avec les talibans c'est un
vieux débat est ce que ce sont quand
même aux états unis considérés comme des
interlocuteurs politiques légitimes en
gros est ce qu'on pactise avec le diable
négocier avec le diable oui parce que
l'accord l'accord qui en place l'ont
très clair que les états unis
n'acceptent pas les talibans comme
entité politique légitime
il ne s'agit pas de queue d'un groupe
avec lequel ils veulent conclure un
accord donc qu'ils ont dit avoir une
formule pour sortir les troupes
américaines et quant à l'avenir de
l'afghanistan s'il va y avoir une
coalition pour diriger le pays une union
de force s'il va y avoir un échange de
prisonniers cela fait partie de l'accord
qui devrait avoir une échange de
prisonniers nous ne savons pas si cela
aura lieu et les etats-unis s'en fiche
tout ce qu'il tout ce qui les intéresse
c'est d'avoir une promesse de la fin des
talibans qui ne vont pas collaborer avec
des jld pour récréer les événements du
11 septembre
et ensuite espérons que les etats-unis
retirent des troupes et qui met fin à
cette guerre la négociation avec des
talibans est ce que ça ne peut pas
clairement se retourner contre les états
unis à court à moyen ou à plus ou moins
long terme
oui ça pourrait se retourner contre les
états unis
si il y à bien des attentats terroristes
contre les états unis au même en europe
et cela pourrait on pourrait trouver que
les talibans sont derrière ces attaques
mais les états unis sont très hypocrite
sur ce sujet parce que
actuellement les états unis et ses
alliés dans l'otan protègent d'al-qaïda
à idleb en syrie et critiquent
sévèrement l'offensive russe pour sortir
al qaïda des bleus tout en sachant que
ellipses et un fief d'al-qaïda et
plusieurs fois par le passé ils ont
essayé de laisser al qaïda sur place
parce que là d'intervention de la russie
en syrie cause des problèmes pour liront
pour d'autres pays dans la région s être
mais si il y à il s'y li a bien un
attentat de la part d'al qaïda qui est
lié aux talibans
alors cela serait bien un problème pour
l'administration de train merci beaucoup
georges samueli chercheur au global le
policier institut d'avoir été avec nous
en direct sur rt france pour notre
rubrique vu de l'extérieur ce soir